now on to cobit 19 vaccine updates many
of you have contacted us
sharing your experience getting
vaccinated some say no lines
others waiting upwards of two hours
sally jaramillo checked out some of the
clinics today and has some
good news to report sally apparently
some clinics have expanded so that means
that they're
minimal that their wait times have
shrunk
yet denise i'm at the las vegas
convention center where
long lines have been the main concern
add to that those waiting times right
so i do want to give you a perspective
especially because this is such a
centralized
location you can see now no lines and
they are open for another half an hour
tonight
i stopped by the heritage park senior
facility in henderson that just opened
today
they're offering 500 vaccinations a day
i did see a good turnout here
but no lines as for the las vegas
convention center
no wait either donald cortorsi got his
second dose today
i didn't have any long lines this time
nor the first
the first time was over at cashman
and here we are at the las vegas
convention center it was quick and
very quick and painless
the heritage park senior facility
vaccination clinic runs through friday i
did find out they are booked
for the rest of this week now for a full
list of hours of operations and where
you can get that vaccine make sure to
visit our website 8newsnow.com reporting
live sally jaramillo
8 news now